surprisingly in this case the answer is
the global object when you don't have a
dot to help you pass a specific binding
for the keyword this JavaScript binds
this by default to the global object
this can be seen as similar to the fact
the JavaScript binds undefined to
positional parameters when we call the
function without enough inputs so if we
had passed no inputs in between these
parentheses we would expect one and two
to be undefined a similar line of
reasoning leads us to the conclusion
that the default object of global would
be bound to this whenever we don't have
a dot the dot is the mechanism by which
we pass in a binding for the keyword
this so without a dot you could expect
some default value to get bound to the
parameter this